.
Leute,
diese Geschichte ist unglaublich.
Die 100.000 Euro
sind nicht angekommen.
Sie haben ja den Beweis bestellt.
Ich habe den Beweis geliefert.
Wo ist das Geld?
- Das ist David Bardens.
David ist Arzt, lebt
und arbeitet derzeit in Schweden.
Nachdem er seine Familie
in Deutschland besucht hat,
treffe ich ihn
am Frankfurter Flughafen,
bevor er nach Schweden zurückfliegt.
Er hat eine
echt skurrile Geschichte erlebt.
Wegen dieser Geschichte
ist er noch Jahre später
immer noch
mit Personenschutz unterwegs.
Aber eins nach dem anderen.
Vor einigen Jahren
war David noch im Medizinstudium,
als er sich
mit einem Biologen anlegte,
der behauptete,
es gäbe keine Masern-Viren.
Es kam zu einem der skurrilsten
Gerichtsprozesse ever.
Holt euch 'nen Tee,
entspannt euch schon mal,
denn ihr werdet
eure Nerven nachher noch brauchen.
Hier kommt die wahre Geschichte
über den 100.000-Euro-Prozess
und eine Masern-Verschwörung.
* Titelmusik *
Wir brauchen für diese Geschichte
ein paar wissenschaftliche Basics.
Hangeln wir die kurz ab. Die Masern
sind uns allen ein Begriff.
Aber wie diese Infektionskrankheit
wirklich aussieht,
wissen die meisten
von uns nicht mehr.
Zum Glück, weil die Krankheit
so selten geworden ist.
Die Krankheit fängt nicht mit diesem
typischen roten Hautausschlag an,
wofür die Masern bekannt sind.
Die Anfangssymptome
gleichen Grippesymptomen
und werden daher oft fehlgedeutet.
In diesen ersten 5 Tagen
vor dem Ausschlag
ist man aber bereits krank
und hoch ansteckend.
In Köln gab es letztes Jahr
z.B.einen Masern-Ausbruch,
der aber zum Glück noch
dank Aufklärung und Impfungen
eingedämmt werden konnte.
Die Folgen
können lebensgefährlich sein.
- Manche können nicht aufstehen.
Wir haben Patienten,
junge Frauen und Männer gehabt,
die eine Woche
in Windeln gelegen haben,
weil sie gar nicht
aus dem Bett gekommen sind.
Dann kann es zu einer
schweren Gehirnentzündung kommen,
und zwar einmal akut,
direkt im Verlauf der Krankheit,
und manchmal,
das ist etwas unheimlich,
dauert das aber 7-8 Jahre,
bis die Hirnschäden auftreten.
In dem Fall
kann man nichts dagegen machen,
das ist eigentlich immer tödlich.
- Diese 2 neuen Studien
zeigen zudem,
wie die Masern auch das Immunsystem
nachhaltig schädigen können.
Immunamnesie ist das Stichwort,
also eine Art
Gedächtnisschwund des Immunsystems.
Normalerweise
bildet unser Immunsystem
nach einer überstandenen
Infektionskrankheit
oder nach einer Impfung Antikörper,
die sich
an die Krankheitserreger erinnern
und beim nächsten Mal angreifen.
Durch eine Masernerkrankung
kann das Immunsystem
diese Erinnerungen verlieren.
So werden wir nicht nur anfälliger
für Infektionskrankheiten,
auch das Sterblichkeitsrisiko
steigt.
Es gibt aber Menschen, die
Krankheiten wie Masern verharmlosen.
Ich hatte die auch als Kind.
Mir hat's nicht geschadet.
Wenn das so ist,
freut mich das für dich, ernsthaft.
Good for you. Und in jedem
anderen Fall würde ich sagen,
es ist euer Körper,
macht mit dem, was ihr wollt.
Aber gerade als werdende Mutter
ist das besonders frustrierend.
Mein Baby kann nach der Geburt
nicht sofort geimpft werden.
Es ist erst mal zu jung.
Es gibt z.B.auch Menschen,
die eine Immunkrankheit haben
und nicht geimpft werden können.
Diese Menschen
sind darauf angewiesen,
dass wir geschützt sind,
dass wir geimpft sind,
dass eine Herdenimmunität besteht.
Besonders gefährlich ist es,
wenn Menschen
die Masern nicht nur verharmlosen,
sondern sogar
Verschwörungstheorien verbreiten.
Dass die Masern
gar keine Infektionskrankheit sind.
Als ich ungefähr
4 Jahre Medizin studiert hatte,
hab ich im Internet 'ne Webseite
gefunden von 'nem Typen,
der ist Biologe,
promovierter Biologe,
und er behauptet ernsthaft,
dass es Infektionserkrankungen
gar nicht gibt.
Der sagt, Bakterien
oder Viren führen nicht dazu,
dass man erkrankt,
sondern alle Erkrankungen
kommen nur durch irgendwelche
psychische Traumen.
Unter "Germanische Neue Medizin"
laufen solche Irrvorstellungen.
Infektionskrankheiten? - Sind alle
eine Erfindung der Pharmaindustrie,
die nur will, dass wir uns impfen
und Medikamente spritzen,
damit die daran Geld verdienen.
Jetzt hat der Mann
auf seiner Webseite
100.000 Euro dafür ausgeschrieben,
dass man ihm eine wissenschaftliche
Untersuchung zuschickt,
die beweist, dass die Masern
als Viren
oder als Viruserkrankung existieren.
Dann hab ich gedacht,
dem zeig ich's.
Ich will dem das beweisen.
Und am besten
will ich dieses Geld nehmen
und in Masern-Impfungen investieren,
um diese Impfgegner
mal so richtig zu ärgern.
Ich wollte natürlich provozieren.
Eigentlich hatte David
nicht ernsthaft damit gerechnet,
dass diese Auslobung
von 100.000 Euro ernst gemeint war.
Dann hab ich den Brief geschrieben,
hab geschrieben,
auf dieser Webseite
hab ich gelesen,
dass Sie 100.000 Euro anbieten
für den Beweis
der Existenz des Masernvirus.
Stimmt das denn wirklich so?
Dann schreibt er mir zurück
und unterschreibt auch:
Ja, ich zahle das Geld gerne aus.
Aber bei Ihren Recherchen
werden Sie sehen,
dass es dieses Masernvirus
überhaupt gar nicht gibt.
Also ging David recherchieren,
er brauchte ein paar Stunden,
um 6 Studien rauszusuchen.
Stern TV hat mal ausgerechnet,
dass ich einen Stundenlohn
von ca. 20.000 Euro hatte.
Dann hab ich ihm diese Publikationen
mit Einschreiben
Rückschein zugestellt,
sodass er unterschreiben musste,
dass er diese bekommen hatte.
- OK, nicht per E-Mail,
sondern so richtig...
- Nicht per E-Mail,
ich habe das offiziell gemacht.
Nach ca.einem Monat oder so
hab ich ihm 'ne Mahnung geschrieben.
Ich hab da geschrieben,
ich hab mein Konto beobachtet
und die 100.000 Euro
sind nicht angekommen.
Sie haben ja den Beweis bestellt.
Ich hab den Beweis geliefert.
Wo ist das Geld?
Aber der Masern-Leugner
wollte diese 6 Studien
nicht als Beweis akzeptieren.
Dann hab ich gedacht,
wer entscheidet eigentlich,
ob ich das Geld bekomme oder nicht?
Ich kann nicht
'ne Waschmaschine bestellen
und dann sagen,
ich bezahl dafür nicht.
Ich hab mir das anders überlegt.
Oder die Waschmaschine
ist eigentlich 'n Trockner oder so.
Da hab ich gedacht, das muss
jetzt 'ne andere Stelle entscheiden,
wer jetzt hier Recht hat.
Also zog David
mit diesem Fall vor Gericht,
und zwar vor das Landgericht
in Ravensburg.
Weil das nicht nur
eine juristische Frage war,
sondern auch eine wissenschaftliche,
wurde von dem Gericht
ein wissenschaftlicher
Gutachter hinzugezogen,
und zwar der Mikrobiologe
Prof.Andreas Podbielski.
Der angeklagte Masern-Leugner
fand es wohl nicht so gut,
dass wissenschaftliche Expertise
hinzugezogen wurde
und versuchte,
sich zu wehren, indem er:
Damit das klar ist:
Es ging hier nicht um eine
grundlegende medizinische Frage,
nämlich gibt es Masernviren
oder nicht? Denn die gibt es ja.
Es ging in diesem Fall um die Frage,
hat David mit seinen 6 Studien
genügend Beweise dargelegt,
um dieses Preisgeld
von 100.000 Euro zu bekommen?
Prof.Podbielski kam zu dem Schluss:
Ja, hat er.
In Ravensburg
wurde dann das Urteil gefällt,
dass ich
diese 100.000 Euro bekommen soll,
weil ich sie mir verdient habe.
Er war natürlich extrem sauer,
v.a., weil da auch die Weltpresse
im Prinzip draufgeschaut hat.
Das war für die Presse
ein gefundenes Fressen.
Ein Impfgegner
lobt 100.000 Euro aus,
und dann holt sie sich jemand ab
und spendet die
an Masern-Impfungen.
Aber, Freunde der Sonne,
bleibt sitzen,
die Geschichte
ist noch lange nicht zu Ende.
Der Masern-Leugner wollte das
nicht auf sich sitzen lassen
und ging in Berufung. Der Fall
ging in die nächste Instanz.
Wir sind dann nochmal
zu einer Gerichtsverhandlung
vom Oberlandesgericht in Stuttgart.
Dort wurde dann anders entschieden.
Freunde, passt auf,
das ist jetzt kein Witz.
Ich habe 6 Studien eingeschickt.
Er hatte aber geschrieben, dass er
eine Publikation haben möchte.
Da in der Auslobung
von nur einer Studie die Rede war,
David aber 6 Studien hatte,
die nur in ihrer Gesamtheit
die Existenz
des Masern-Virus bewiesen,
hatte er aus rein formellen Gründen
keinen Anspruch
auf die 100.000 Euro Preisgeld.
Der Impfgegner bekam also
tatsächlich Recht vor Gericht.
Ich hab mich unglaublich
über die Juristen aufgeregt.
Ich fand, das war
wirklich ein komisches Urteil,
weil ich's einfach nicht verstehe.
In diesem Fall ist es
aus wissenschaftlicher Sicht
ohnehin unglaublich schwer,
irgendetwas
mit nur einer Studie zu beweisen.
Wenn ihr schon länger maiLab schaut,
wisst ihr auch,
dass Forschung
Sammeln von Puzzleteilen ist
und dass eine Studie alleine
selten irgendetwas
Grundlegendes beweisen kann,
sondern es sind Puzzleteile,
die zusammenpassen müssen,
verschiedene Experimente,
die in sich konsistent sein müssen,
um ein Gesamtbild zu ergeben.
David versuchte daraufhin,
den Fall vor
den Bundesgerichtshof zu bringen.
Der Bundesgerichtshof hat das
nicht weiter verhandeln wollen.
Jetzt könnt ihr euch vorstellen,
was seitdem passiert ist.
Der Masern-Leugner
und seine Anhänger
verbreiten seitdem die Falschinfos,
dass das Oberlandesgericht
in Stuttgart
und der Bundesgerichtshof
beide bestätigt hätten,
dass es keine Masernviren gibt,
was natürlich gelogen ist.
Hinzu kommt, dass er:
Was meinst du, was ihm
der ganze Trubel gebracht hat?
Das ist natürlich
ein extrem eitler Mensch,
der sehr gerne
Aufmerksamkeit wollte.
Das ist jemand,
der sein Geld verdient mit Büchern.
Bücher wie diese hier: "Impfen:
Völkermord im 3.Jahrtausend"
oder "Impfen und AIDS:
Der neue Holocaust".
Es ist ganz typisch
für Verschwörungstheoretiker,
also achtet mal drauf,
die Aussagen sind immer so extrem,
so radikal, so empörend,
dass die meisten Menschen davon
zwar nicht angesprochen werden,
weil die meisten Menschen zum Glück
vernünftig, skeptisch genug sind.
Aber diejenigen,
die sie damit erreichen,
sind dann ganz anfällige,
ganz verletzliche Personen.
Das sind z.B.Menschen, die selbst
'ne schwere Krankheit haben
oder jemanden in der Familie haben,
der krank ist,
die vom medizinischen System
enttäuscht sind
und jetzt
verzweifelt nach Antworten suchen.
Dabei wird leider nicht nur Angst,
sondern auch Hass geschürt.
David wurde so massiv bedroht
und auch seine Familie,
dass er heute, Jahre später,
immer noch nur mit Personenschutz
in die Öffentlichkeit geht.
- Würdest du das
so nochmal machen, im Nachhinein?
Ich würde es
auf jeden Fall noch mal machen.
Ich denke, dass ich mich wirklich...
Es geht gegen meine Natur
und gegen meine Persönlichkeit,
mich da nicht dagegenzustemmen,
wenn jemand so 'nen Unsinn behauptet
und damit auch noch
die Gesundheit von Leuten
und Kindern in Gefahr bringt.
Das ist doch nicht normal.
Also ich reg mich da
fürchterlich darüber auf.
Nee, also ich lass das
so nicht stehen.
Ich kann David einerseits
nur zu gut nachvollziehen,
andererseits seh ich das Ganze
auch ein bisschen anders.
Vielleicht, weil ich
schon so lange YouTube mache
und über so viele Verschwörungs-
theorien gestolpert bin,
die letztendlich alle
eine ähnliche Taktik fahren.
Die Verschwörungstheoretiker
sind meistens super provokativ,
konfrontativ,
sie fordern Wissenschaftler heraus,
in der Öffentlichkeit
sich ihnen zu stellen.
Wenn sie ignoriert werden,
sagen sie natürlich:
Seht ihr, keiner traut sich,
mir zu widersprechen.
Andererseits,
wenn man dann auf sie zugeht,
akzeptieren sie sowas
wie Wissenschaft nicht als Beweis.
So ein Quatsch,
das kann jeder behaupten.
Das finde ich besonders gefährlich,
denn wenn ein Laie da zuschaut,
steht für den
im Zweifel Aussage gegen Aussage.
Es hat nicht jeder die Zeit oder
die wissenschaftliche Ausbildung,
um sich sämtliche Studien
im Detail durchzulesen
oder seitenlange Gutachten.
Das, was ich erreicht habe,
war im Prinzip,
dass ich auf die Masern-Impfung
und die Masern als Erkrankung
aufmerksam gemacht habe.
Ich habe
keine Gelegenheit ausgelassen,
um für Impfungen zu werben.
Und ich hab irgendwo signalisiert,
he, Leute, was ihr im Netz treibt,
seid da mal schön vorsichtig.
Ihr könnt nicht
jeden Mist behaupten,
ohne dass euch jemand widerspricht
und das Konsequenzen haben kann.
Für mich persönlich ist dieser Fall
dennoch ein Warnbeispiel dafür,
dass man mit Vernunft
bei Verschwörungstheoretikern
nicht gewinnen kann.
Am Ende sind nur sie es,
die Aufmerksamkeit gewinnen,
und wenn es richtig blöd läuft,
sogar Gerichtsprozesse.
Eine Sache darf man auch nicht
vergessen, das sagt David auch:
Gerade diese ganzen extremen
radikalen Stimmen im Netz
sind meistens
nur eine sehr kleine Minderheit,
die einfach sehr laut schreit
und deswegen nicht
unseren Diskurs bestimmen sollte.
Der Anteil der radikalen Impfgegner
im Deutschland
beläuft sich auf einen niedrigen
einstelligen Prozentsatz.
Die meisten Menschen,
die nicht richtig geimpft sind,
sind es,
weil sie es vergessen haben,
weil sie nicht wissen,
wo ihr Impfpass ist
oder ob der noch up to date ist.
Fühlt ihr euch angesprochen?
An alle Leute,
die hier zuschauen:
Ich kann euch wirklich empfehlen,
geht mit euren Impfpässen zum Arzt
und fragt einfach mal nach,
ob ihr alle Impfungen bekommen habt.
Und lasst euch nachimpfen,
wenn sich zeigt,
dass euch
noch eine Masern-Impfung z.B.fehlt.
Das ist super wichtig,
nicht nur für eure Gesundheit.
Ihr schützt euch ja damit
gegen gefährliche Erkrankungen,
Sondern auch,
um die Gesellschaft zu schützen,
um eure Mitmenschen zu schützen,
Babys zu schützen,
die zu jung sind,
um geimpft zu werden,
kranke Leute zu schützen, die
auch keine Impfung erhalten können
oder ein schlechtes
Immunsystem haben.
Geht einfach zum Arzt
mit eurem Impfbuch
und fragt mal nach,
ob ihr wirklich alle Impfungen habt.
Kann ich nur unterstreichen
und wenn ihr möchtet,
teil dieses Video bitte gerne.
Ich fänd's wichtig,
wenn viele Menschen
von dieser Geschichte erfahren.
Wir sehen uns bald
und bis dahin, bleibt sicher.
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von funk (2019)